cryptocurrency had an absolute explosive
2021. so what about solana one of the
newest cryptocurrencies on the market it
had an explosive 2021 but has drawn down
significantly since then at the start of
2021 solano was about three dollars
going all the way up to an all-time high
of about 260 dollars that is insane
growth but since then it's actually down
about 67 from its all-time high and it's
trading about 42
lower than last monday 42 drawdown in
just one week that is wild we have a
quote from alex a senior financial
analyst at fx pro he says alarmingly the
sharp reversal on friday was not
followed by any meaningful bounce some
observers point out that this is a
worrying signal suggesting further
market declines as we have not seen a
final capitulation without capitulation
the markets will remain with an overhang
of sellers what he's talking about here
is that since we did not see a
correction this actually could go
farther and draw down further and
further and further before we see an
explosive what i don't like to see is
that all these cryptocurrencies have
been correlated including solana with
bitcoin ethereum and others so what do
the big banks think about this bank of
america released the report last week
that was calling solana saying it could
be the visa of the digital asset
ecosystem essentially saying that solana
can plug into the digital asset
ecosystem and actually provide that
transactional value and medium of
exchange for certain assets solana has
had an absolute massive year they
settled over 50 billion transactions
compared to visa which is actually the
global payments giant
164.7 billion ending last year in
september so solana has had over 11
billion in total value locked solano
also has been used to mint over 5.7
million nfts it has grown immense
traction over the last year we're going
to see where solana goes but it's
certainly competing with ethereum right
now as a medium of exchange sauna is
optimizing for scalability and speed and
outcast here puts it perfectly solana
prioritizes scalability but a relatively
less decentralized and secure blockchain
has trade-offs illustrated by several
network performance issues since
inception ethereum prioritizes
decentralization and security but at the
expense of scalability which has led to
periods of network congestion and
transaction fees that are occasionally
larger than the value of the transaction
being sent solana and ethereum are both
optimizing for different things and
they're competing to be that medium of
exchange we're gonna see which model is
actually successful but they are
certainly gonna have a fun 2022